tonight on the new reality the narrow
world of sports we can get the league's
going look if there's something to look
forward to and at a time like this we
need all the help we can get the risks
of reopening too soon there's trillions
of dollars that have been lost here but
at the heart of that is public health
problem it is the virus
kovat 19 conspiracy theories going viral
you should look at the credibility of
the people who are trying to convince
you that they're right when they don't
have any science to prove it a coming
Maul apocalypse we're gonna see a big
rethink in terms of what a quarter
unquote shopping center really is and
pandemic pets pretty interested in whose
day-to-day activities
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen we're all
missing things about the way life used
to be thousands of people of course have
lost loved ones to covet 19 and for them
life will never be the same
others are yearning for just a bit of
what life was like before the pandemic
something to lift our spirits something
to rally around sports is what does that
for millions of people Nelson Mandela
said Sports has the power to inspire the
power to unite people in a way that
little else does sports he said can
create hope where once there was only
despair we could all use some hope right
now professional sports are working out
ways to come back fans can't be there in
person but preparations are underway to
drop the first Popkin throw the first
pitch in this kovat era Eric Sorenson
looks at how and when the games will
begin again in golf safe distance is
easy when there's no gallery expensive
fairways and golfers don't have to get
close to each other a round of golf for
charity went off without a hitch or a
cough and so the world of sports is
getting back in the swing pandemic or
not car racing naturally separates
drivers from one another
NASCAR gave us our first look at a major
North American event in front of an
empty grandstand baseball already up and
running in South Korea can also be
played with limited contact but when
European soccer kicked off once more one
thing became clear
you can't play contact sports without
the contact it looks and certainly
sounds different in a cavernous Stadium
basically you have to have some
integrity to the game for sure
Bob Stella is a veteran of sports
marketing well there might be certainly
a little emotion missing without having
fans there but I think guys will we'll
get used to it
I think they'll play hard though they'll
be proud you know play for pride in a
society surrounded by a highly
infectious coronavirus the challenge is
to cocoon the players and their games
from the threat of contracting or
spreading the disease the NBA wants to
pull its gargantuans from exposed public
service to cloister the entire league at
Disney in Florida the NHL in its own way
plans to isolate in two
city's lead commissioner Gary Bettman
says the competition comes second I want
to make clear that the health and safety
of our players coaches essential support
staff in our communities are paramount
health protocols will differ but the
basics are first the outside world where
kovat 19 is present a transition zone
where athletes and key officials will be
tested repeatedly and verified to be Co
vid free and then the inner sanctum
where the games are played it's hoped in
a pristine setting and close contact in
competition is allowed and justified
with full on contact something frowned
upon everywhere else is there a risk yes
but it can be managed says this
epidemiologist living with some
uncertainty and a little bit of risk
while we're in the pre vaccine era of
Koba 19 if there is a safe way to do it
and if the public health authorities
deem that it something that can be done
safely I think it's a completely
acceptable thing to start back up again
disease specialists warned that if the
virus spreads on a team it could force a
shutdown but the aim is to prevent that
there may indeed be cases of kovat 19
but says one NBA insider the plan is to
respond swiftly before it spreads and
carry on the NBA would then isolate in
quarantine that player continued the
daily testing protocols they would have
no stoppage of play Bobst Elex says the
league's can't allow themselves to be
paralyzed by a single kovin 19 case the
point right now is if someone does test
positive they can't shut the whole
operation down they have to be able to
extricate that person and isolate that
person so I mean just like everywhere
else there being extra careful what will
be missing of course are the fans the
excitement they bring and the billions
they spend the spectacle just one year
ago
basketball diehards squished together in
Toronto no fear of contagion now it just
seems like a bygone era
[Applause]
how long will this stark new normal last
and at what cost the three most valuable
sports franchises in the country are
right here down the street at the Rogers
Center where the Toronto Blue Jays play
and here at the Scotiabank Arena the
Toronto Raptors in the Toronto Maple
Leafs now the three Toronto teams along
with the Montreal Canadiens are the only
teams in the country valued at more than
1 billion dollars so a lot of money is
at stake it's estimated that the big
leagues involved stand to lose five and
a half billion dollars because of what
happened this spring more than 3 billion
is from the fans that's the loss of
tickets and food and merchandise and the
other two billion is from TV revenue now
they may not get the fans back but there
is money to be recovered from the
television revenue one reason why they
want to come back this summer I don't
think any business model could have
anticipated this richard powers studies
sports and business he says without fans
in the stands thousands of jobs have
been lost and minor-league and amateur
sports are really suffering as the
public stops buying tickets in
communities everywhere they're very
dependent on you know literally bums and
seats there are thousands of jobs at
risk here many of those won't come back
without spectators in the seats but he
says big leagues will get by because
millions will tune in to see Connor
McDavid and Sidney Crosby or Pascal
siakam and LeBron James fight for a
championship even in the wrong season
the leagues that means they keep their
television revenues they keep your
sponsorship revenues now they're taking
a significant hit as we mentioned with
the lack of spectators at least with the
sponsors and the TV contracts they can
make something out of what appears to be
nothing right now the luckiest of the
big league sports is American football
the pandemic arrived out of season and
the biggest Enterprise in all of sport
plans to restart on time in September
Major League Baseball is planning its
season by playing half the usual number
of games historically a day at the
ballpark was always seen as an escape
from the bigger problems of the world
the national pastime gets on the
bandwagon
800 million dollars is the contribution
of baseball fans to the bond drive
during the Second World War a very
different crisis baseball was viewed as
indispensable to the morale of Americans
so major league ball kept going during
the war there may not be quite that
sentimentality today but big-time sports
are an important part of the fabric of
society that we're in this together and
as the Toronto Raptors proved last year
Sports can unify a lot of people around
a bouncing ball sport is a significant
part of our culture and we miss that and
if we can get the leagues going I think
people will really appreciate that it'll
give them something to look forward to
and at a time like this we need all the
help we can get to get through this this
pandemic for fans there is a rhythm and
a continuity in the sports calendar you
start the year and hockey and basketball
are in full swing you have big events
like the Super Bowl then there's curling
for some fans March Madness for others
and here comes the Masters baseball
starts the playoffs all kinds of events
start up in the spring except this year
a black hole everything disappeared
now the attempt is to begin that rhythm
again not just baseball in the
summertime or the CFL but basketball
playoffs in July the Indy 500 in August
as the NFL begins silver the Kentucky
Derby and how about the Stanley Cup in
the autumn and some sports will not
happen till next year
March Madness Wimbledon soccer's euro
championship and the Tokyo Olympics the
impact on sports will be felt for at
least another year and who knows how
soon the crowds can come back to watch
and cheer whether it's professional or
youth and amateur sports and playing the
games they will be a matter of trial and
error and risk as long as the pandemic
lasts
there's almost no escaping the deluge of
information about the new coronavirus
were both confused and riveted trying to
work out what's real and important and
what's not and Kovac 19 is acting as an
accelerant to conspiracy theories the
digital era we live in is blended with
an analog virus a contagion that lingers
on surfaces waiting for a human host
where it can replicate fear of this
virus is powerful and it's intensified
all kinds of nefarious misinformation
and disinformation that's spreading
online
the result is an explosive force that
could have catastrophic consequences you
cannot make people wear a mask it's not
our laws at all this is just made up by
Bill Gates in them it is 20/20 but at
times it feels like we flash back to
medieval times fear of an invisible
enemy is everywhere and it's making some
people do crazy things before
coronavirus we feared technology would
overtake us undermine us create a world
where we can't tell what's real and
what's fake
president Trump is a total and complete
this deep fake video for example was
made using machine learning moving
forward we need to be more vigilant with
what we trust from the internet that's a
time when we need to rely on trusted
news sources today it's not deep fakes
and sophisticated technology that's
insidious and destabilizing
it's a virus an invisible enemy is swept
across the world so fast and killed so
many even modern hospitals with the best
technology have been overwhelmed Kovac
19 is moving faster than we can and is
outsmarted our best scientists we still
have no effective weapon against it that
has sown fear and uncertainty
disinformation misinformation going
viral many there are spouting the same
conspiracy theories that we hear in the
United States gaining traction all over
the world there's a lot of psychological
research behind why people find the
simplicity of conspiratorial
killing rene der estes studies how
disinformation spreads online the idea
that someone somewhere is is maliciously
pulling the strings rate so the world is
not out of your control of someone
somewhere is deliberately doing these
things to hurt you then there's a
villain and there's someone who can
direct your anger there's a firehose of
false information memes and hashtags
spewed at us from multiple platforms
shared millions of times and fiction
morphs into what some mistakenly believe
is fact conspiracies that lived online
have now burst out into the real world
online conspiracists have cobbled
together a narrative not grounded in any
fact that accuses powerful people like
Bill Gates of releasing the virus as a
ploy to launch a genocide 'el mass
vaccination campaign for decades Gates
has been working on depopulation and
dictatorial control plans on global
politics
this Italian MP even gave a long speech
in Parliament about it calling Bill
Gates a vaccine criminal the real goal
of all of this is total control the
spread of such outlandish charges may
seem silly but the consequences could be
catastrophic if large portions of the
public believe the intent of gates and
public health experts is nefarious they
could be convinced a corona virus
vaccine if one is discovered will be
dangerous many may refuse it there's
evidence that's already starting a poll
in the u.s. found half of all Americans
who named Fox News as their primary TV
news source believe Bill Gates is
plotting to use a kovin 19 vaccination
campaign to implant microchips in
billions of people to track their
movements 44% of voters who cast ballots
for Donald Trump in 2016
believe it too even though neither Fox
nor Trump has promoted that
theory and a Canadian poll for the
School of Journalism at Carleton
University found nearly half of
Canadians believed at least one of four
conspiracy theories 26 percent believed
kovat 19 was engineered as a bio weapon
in a Chinese lab and released into the
general population and then there's
planned emic exposing their deadly
secrets that minions a big pharma waged
war dr. Malcolm X it looks like a slick
documentary and is like gospel for
believers dr. Mike Ovitz is naming names
of those behind the plague of corruption
that places all of human life in danger
the former research scientist who
features in it makes lots of claims not
backed up by evidence including that
wearing a mask is dangerous because it
activates your own virus she was
discredited in 2011 after the journal
Science retracted her paper on a
supposed link between a virus and
chronic fatigue syndrome her fall from
grace was steep she was arrested for a
period of time I think for stealing lab
equipment so this was sort of a
disreputable figure who had really
become kind of a fringe conference
speaker since her paper was retracted
but at this particular point in time she
had a new book out and claimed that her
paper was retracted and other you know
other things had happened to her that
were bad in her career because of
Anthony Fauci who has risen to a
position of prominence in the United
States in our government's response to
Kovac on May 4th planned emic was posted
to Facebook YouTube and Vimeo it spread
unchecked and in just over a week was
shared linked viewed and commented on
more than 8 million times 2 million on
Facebook alone there's a lot of overlap
and conspiratorial communities online
there's a research that shows that if
you believe in one conspiracy theory
you're likely to believe in others so in
the case of planned emic what you
started to see was the queuing on
community picked it up this is a
conspiratorial community not in the
United States and the Q&M community has
a lot of overlap with what we can call
the kind of more mainstream pro-trump
for a president Trump community the
Mogga
community if you will make
on May 11th YouTube Facebook and Vimeo
took the video down and fact checkers
have worked to debunk it but it lives on
and keeps being shared facts aren't as
sexy as a conspiracy when you're sharing
something that's being billed as here is
the secret dark truth of the way of the
world that's much more interesting and
compelling and more likely to get
someone to click you have to create
content that's emotionally resonant hey
everybody its dr. Zubin Damania an
actual medical experts like this
Stanford trained doctor are pushing back
with their own online videos I can't
believe I'm wasting my time doing this
but I just want to stop getting messages
about it because it's really frustrating
to think that people are this fricking
stupid this one debunking plan Demick
has been viewed on youtube more than 3
million times you should look at the
credibility of the people who are trying
to convince you that they're right when
they don't have any science to prove it
the UN is working to counter the
conspiracies - we're partnering with a
also a an organization called first
draft news that is closely monitoring
the spreading of misinformation where
it's coming from
and we will prioritize audiences that
are receiving this misinformation and
sharing it as well it's hoping to
mobilize millions of digital first
responders to counter misinformation
[Applause]
claiming 5g cell towers for spreading
the disease has led to arson attacks in
Quebec and around the world accusations
China manufactured the virus have led to
racist insults and assaults and Bill
Gates who five years ago warned the
biggest potential killer the world faced
is not war but a pandemic and who has
spent billions on life-saving vaccines
is now public enemy number one -
conspiracy theorists who are infecting
millions with misinformation that could
be as dangerous as the virus itself
where does this leave the news consumer
well with me is Craig Silverman he's
media editor of BuzzFeed he's an
award-winning author and journalist in
one of the world's leading experts on
online misinformation he started using
the term fake news back in 2014 long
before President Trump weaponized it
Craig you have edited a verification
handbook on media manipulation and in it
you make the point that everything in
the digital world can be gained and
manipulated and there are a variety of
people and entities with incentives to
do it now that that world has met this
real-world virus what has it led to I
feel like it's a high-water mark in
terms of conspiracy theories
misinformation disinformation just a
wide range of you know very confusing
often misleading information polluting
our environment and we've sort of been
leading up to this point to a certain
extent things have progressively kind of
been getting a little bit worse and
worse but you have a massive global
event like a pandemic which naturally
unleashes conspiracy theories you do
that in this digital environment and
this is what we're experiencing right
now a really high watermark with in
terms of this false and misleading info
what's the onus on social media
platforms who all profit from this junk
to refuse to let it live on their sites
we've seen Twitter fact-check president
Trump's tweets for the first time not
not about coronavirus actually but but
mail-in ballots Facebook's Mark
Zuckerberg though says it's not up to
platforms to be truth police what is
your view well they absolutely have
responsibility here and and they have
acknowledged that responsibility if we
think about how things have changed
since the end of 2016 they were doing
very little to almost nothing to combat
false and dangerous claims on their
platform and now pretty much every major
platform has teams that are dedicated to
reviewing this information Facebook
funds dozens of fact checkers around the
world so it's kind of a strange thing
when Mark Zuckerberg comes out and says
well it's not up to us to be the
arbiters of truth they also talk to the
other side of their mouths saying how
much they've invested in the kind of
efforts to
rid their platform of dangerous and
misleading and false information so when
he says he doesn't want to be doesn't
think they should be truth police you
think that specifically relates to
politicians yes I mean that's the only
sort of interpretation of that comment
that could make it partially true
because they absolutely are helping
arbitrate and decide on the veracity of
content now they've outsourced that to a
certain extent to third party fact
checkers but Facebook has introduced the
program is spending millions and
millions of dollars a year on people who
are whose job description is absolutely
falling into the arbiters of truth level
and Facebook has decided that they don't
want fact checkers fact-checking
political ads and they don't want them
fact-checking political speech and that
in itself is a pretty controversial line
to draw let's talk about the planned
emic it was taken down from a number of
sites but you know it keeps popping up
and it's being shared anyway is there a
way that that can actually be stopped or
is the online ecosystem just too big to
uncover nerville that that it's never
going to happen I think it is a really
good example of perhaps what we can
expect from these platforms at least at
this moment in time and the reality is
that they are too big for them to
actually be able to enforce them
completely and so something like the
planned emic really exploits that
because they know that sure maybe at
some point it gets fact-check and it
starts to be flagged for removal by
facebook itself but they know that they
can get it uploaded by other people in
fact the filmmaker
when he released it he said listen
everyone go download the film because we
know it's going to get removed and we
want you to reload it elsewhere so it
was really part of their marketing
campaign you could say Craig there's
misinformation which is spreading wrong
information and disinformation which is
deliberately spreading wrong information
designed to deceive what do we know
about who is doing this when it comes to
kovat 19 is it individuals or state
actors or both we've got a wide range of
different actors with different
motivations and so you talked about
misinformation it's an important
distinction I think there are a lot of
very well-meaning people who are
uncertain who are looking for guidance
and help around navigating this novel
Rhona virus and they will at times
unintentionally spread false and
misleading information so there is a lot
of that happening and then you have the
sort of deliberate bad actors and
frankly they factor in those
well-meaning people they try to design
their disinformation so it appeals to
the beliefs to the biases to the fears
of all of us which might cause us to not
only consume it but to then we share it
and in terms of those bad actors with
the coronavirus we're certainly seeing a
lot of kind of existing alternative
health influencers people who've already
staked out their turth whether it's anti
vaccine activists or people like that
who are really seizing this as their
moment to spread their particular
message there is state involvement in
particular if you look right now there's
a huge propaganda war being waged
between the US and China over the
origins of the virus and blame for it
and there are other state actors
involved as well but I also think we
have to be aware that a lot of people
are thinking that a vaccine is going to
be the moment when all of this starts to
recede but that's actually going to be
the moment when very organised health
information communities like anti
vaccine activists are going to be moving
to the next level of their campaign to
try and create doubt and fear around a
vaccine do you think that conspiracy
theories around that in kovat 19
generally could become as dangerous as
the virus itself I think it actually
could potentially be even worse in the
sense that if you actually create
hesitancy among the population to take a
vaccine that has gone through the proper
procedures and been tested just like you
know so many of the vaccines we all get
as a regular part of our life and
vaccines that have saved hundreds of
millions maybe even billions of lives
around the world over time and these
last few months have been high-water
marks for disinformation and
misinformation I'm very worried about
the groundwork being laid to really cast
out about vaccines and which could cause
potentially more death and more
suffering
still ahead restriction rule as the best
way to solve the economic crisis is to
solve the public health crisis the truth
and consequences of opening up too soon
plus a mayday for moles I don't think
that they're going to be irrelevant
but I definitely think that they're
going to be changing the new reality for
shopping centers and the people who work
there and up next it was a total wimp
from chickens to puppies the animals
filling our pandemic void
[Music]
as we adjust to this new reality some
members of our families have been big
fans of it pretty much since day one our
pets especially dogs are getting more
face time with their humans than they
have possibly ever and what do we get
back well all that unconditional love at
least from the dogs cats of course give
it when they feel like it a lot of
people have decided this is the
opportune time to get a new pet and our
micro lei is one of them
check out this handsome guy no no no
look down the other handsome guy that's
Magnus the Pug a 4 month old
memory-making a pandemic puppy pugs
if you didn't know really like to zoom
around and the cure to the zoomies we've
since learned is a collar and leash his
stubbornness has been remarkable trying
to go for a morning walk as opposed to
but entertaining in a way that it's
exactly what my family needed after
being thrust into isolation for my
little girl this pandemic puppy has been
everything
[Music]
remember the early days of isolation and
her feelings were all over the place
scared sad frustrated and bored in
Calgary Chelsea Simpson found herself at
home with little to do and then she
remembered a conversation with her dad
basically my dad told me about a year
ago if I could keep a plant alive for a
year he'd get me a puppy
well the plant lived so now she has
beans a mini poodle she's slightly
obsessed with he's very precious with
limited human interaction beans much
like Magnus has filled a void and not
just in her life it should come as no
surprise beans has an instagram page
which is far more popular than she ever
dreamed it would be people are pretty
interested in his day to day activities
so I think people are just kind of bored
but it's been fun like my friends
obviously love watching him on social
media if there's one thing people
initially had a lot of it was time
certain things became scarce toilet
paper and cleaning products the Nintendo
switch video game system and dogs
the Toronto Humane Society placed 71
dogs into foster homes in February and
then 141 in March scammers took note
putting up fake ads for puppies the
anti-fraud centre saw almost as many
cases in the first four months of 2020
as it did all of last year and young
Kendrick rad more had his sights set on
a Havanese puppy he wants to name speedy
except the breeder his family chose had
already sold the first two litters of
the year so we're actually not so well
they know the puppy is coming they also
have to wait which isn't going to be
easy even for a six-year-old with so
much compassion for animals he asked his
friends to donate to a zoo or sanctuary
in lieu of birthday presents I know just
waiting well we're doing a lot of
you learn a lot about this dog before we
get the dog it shouldn't be much of a
surprise to anyone that puppies have
become the pandemic super pet how do we
know this science studies have shown
that dogs have the innate ability to
reduce stress in our lives and they know
when to step in because they're able to
read our facial expressions so in
essence every dog has the potential to
be paw patrol but dogs also take a
commitment level not everyone can offer
which is why the yips pandemic puppy is
actually a pair of chickens they've
rented until the fall cocoa and vanilla
offer up a fresh egg and then spend the
day running around doing chicken things
before going back to their coop the
spectacle of it all has become
surprisingly therapeutic for the cooped
up kids it was a total whim I guess I
had this late urge to have livestock but
I figured this is the only summer we're
gonna be here the entirety of it we're
not traveling and I needed something to
get them off iPads
saying goodbye in the fall to Coco the
stupid in vanilla the stubborn will be
hard just as a return to normalcy will
be on the dogs who have gotten used to
having their new best friends around all
day long let's go but right now I'd
better go walk the dog again come on
let's go
coming up slow and steady wins the race
to open or not to open there's no
perfect formula no country has the
perfect formula now Canada and the world
are getting back to business
[Music]
the biggest challenge all countries face
right now is striking the right balance
between easing the economy back towards
something near normal
while not risking getting so many people
congregating together that the virus
takes hold all over a game it raises the
question how fast is too fast as summer
approaches especially in places where
infection rates are low some are already
ignoring physical distancing guidelines
and not wearing masks and businesses
can't stay closed indefinitely the
economic impact is massive more than 40
million Americans have filed jobless
claims it hasn't been that bad since the
Great Depression
in Canada it's estimated over 40 billion
dollars has been paid out to Canadians
who applied for the Canada emergency
response benefit and the virus is not
vanished we still don't have any weapon
against it if we reopen too fast there's
a risk it's a matter of life and death
and prosperity or poverty to explore
this I'm joined by dr. Peter singer he
has special advisor to the
director-general of the World Health
Organization and he happens to be
Canadian dr. singer is in Geneva dr.
singer thanks for taking the time the
World Health Organization is constant in
its messaging that were not near the end
of this pandemic in fact we're still at
the beginning as restrictions begin to
bees what is your greatest concern well
the greatest concern is that the virus
resurgence and so their restrictions
have to be eased slowly carefully in a
stepwise way and that's actually the way
to deal with that with that fear the
modern world of course has never been
through anything like this as you watch
countries tackle this taking different
approaches to reopening are there basic
guidelines on best practice yes there
are and the key the real heart of the
guideline and the guideline that's put
out by the World Health Organization is
to break the chain of transmission to
find the virus to find the cases isolate
the cases trace the contacts quarantine
the contacts from a can
in perspective you might say quit the
virus in the penalty box that is at the
heart of guidelines on easing
restrictions well you know South Korea's
uses the example of doing that to
contact tracing the the testing the
quarantine and they kept Kovac 19 from
spreading better than a lot of other
countries but now there's a spike in
cases there as well and South Korea is
shutting down public spaces bars clubs
and sporting venues are being advised to
close what does that tell you tells me
that there's no perfect formula no
country has the perfect formula even the
best countries the best practices here
run into setbacks and then need to
recalibrate that and we see that not
just in South Korea but actually in
every country that's doing well and that
says that the trick here is to go slow
and steady slow and steady wins the race
and also it's very important for
countries to learn from each other
because they all follow a slightly
different path and it will be important
I think for not just Canada as a whole
the different parts of Canada to learn
from different countries and and parts
of other countries because it's a very
variable situation and that cross
learning is really critical let me ask
you about the antibody tests you know
there was a lot of hope that they would
be used to show who can safely go back
to work now there's evidence of course
that they're not that reliable what's
the latest advice from the wh o on
antibody tests there's many of those on
the market WH o doesn't feel we're at
the point where there's enough validity
testing enough data really behind any of
them to rely upon them certainly not for
clinical decisions even though in the
context of research they are are used
for example to see in a hard-hit
community what proportion of people have
antibodies and that number by the way
Donna is disturbing because on average
let's say it's 10 percent that means 90%
of the people are still vulnerable to
the virus which is why easing back on
lockdown
or watching the virus spread around the
world is so concerning because most of
the world is still vulnerable to this
virus and that's why there's really no
cause for complacency you know poverty
kills too not as quickly as this virus
but having people out of work leads to
financial hardship and bankruptcy and
psychological distress and domestic
abuse so can the world really afford to
wait until we get a vaccine to fully
reopen the health consequences and the
economic consequences are often pitted
against each other one or the other
that's not really maybe the best way to
characterize it because the economic
consequences flow from the health
consequences you know there's trillions
of dollars that have been lost here but
at the heart of that is the public
health problem it is the virus is the
best way to solve the economic crisis is
to solve the public health crisis do you
think it's likely that we are going to
have to keep living physically distant
lives for a long long time you know I
think that the idea of a magic bullet
that one day will snap our fingers and
this will all be gone in an instant I
think we really have to take a reality
check on that idea a vaccine certainly
could help highly effective therapies
could help but we're still for the
foreseeable future for the months ahead
going to have to live with this virus
going to have to accommodate to it and
hopefully one day soon there will be a
vaccine
next on the new reality there's no way
to get around it or candy-coated a
retail crisis and that's gonna be really
painful not just for some brands but
it'll be painful for consumers as well
wilco bid 19 mean the end of the
shopping mall
[Music]
so many things we used to take for
granted are now off-limits from hugging
old friends to going to the mall Cobin
19 has changed how we shop congregating
in malls to shop or just to hang out
seems a long way off right now even
before the pandemic was declared many
were struggling to survive not all of
them will and those that do are in for
some big changes Sean O'Shay explains
well they don't think that they're going
to be irrelevant but I definitely think
that they're going to be changing
we're gonna see a big rethink in terms
of what a quote-unquote shopping center
really is and if it's even legitimate to
call it a shopping center anymore
but if they had not great reason to go
four months ago they're gonna have much
less reason to go in four months or by
2021 that trip to the mall when it's
possible may not be the same some
Canadians may decide never to go back
there and that may affect thousands of
lives we are gonna have a crisis in the
commercial real estate market there's no
way to get around it or candy-coated the
cost to people who work these malls of
Commerce could be enormous
according to futurist Doug Stephens
clients pay him to look down the retail
road and the view isn't good we could be
facing a retail refugee crisis in fact
you know it is the largest employer in
the in the country the retail and
hospitality industries the kovat 19
pandemic has left shopping malls in much
of the country closed including in
Ontario to get people back to the malls
they will need to really convince people
that they're safe and that there's
something to go for that sense of
purpose of retail malls has been
flagging for years according to
journalist marina Straus she spent 40
years as a reporter at The Globe and
Mail the last 20 covering the retail
sector the activities became more it
became easier to shop online
blaah is a far cry from how shopping
malls were conceived back in the 50s
let's see just how a shopping can be fun
real fun at this modern and convenient
shopping center
one of the first malls Hillsdale built
in San Mateo California it was 1956 yes
shopping is fun at Hillsdale and because
it is we believe that people have come
to know us in more ways than one 60
years ago the one-stop shopping mall
retailers considered stay-at-home
suburban mothers their target audience
and to give mother a little more freedom
for her shopping original vision of it
back in the 50s that it was really about
a place where community came together
and services were were clustered
together shopping malls were typically
anchored by a large department store
tenant
us that meant stores like Macy's and
Eaton's you'll always find a look that's
right for you look there it is it's
perfect Canada names like eating's oh
yeah Richard love it
Eden's collapsed in debt two decades ago
Sears which bought it went out of
business two years ago and 118 year old
JC Penney one of the oldest American
department stores filed for bankruptcy
just two weeks ago kovat 19 didn't
create the problems faced by the retail
industry they faced failure after
failure for decades but the pandemic is
speeding up the pace of the shopping
malls evolution what kovat 19 is really
doing is its pushing the retail industry
out of the industrial age of retail and
into the digital age of retail and
that's gonna be really painful not just
for some brands but it'll be painful for
consumers as well you know just in terms
of the changing shopping habits that are
gonna be required
it's one thing to line up in a pandemic
for necessities like groceries but even
for essentials and most everything else
there's no longer much need the internet
is the biggest big-box store in the
world anything I want is in that store
24 hours a day
Amazon feeds a rising consumer demand
for choice and speed they'll drive me to
a shopping center the product comes to
you so who even needs the shopping mall
where we are going to see stores clothes
we are going to see more dark spaces in
malls that's not going to attract more
people either when retailers really
begin closing stores as we suspect they
will and have already begun to do so and
when they really start rethinking the
size of the footprint and saying you
know could we take a 200 thousand square
foot store down to 50,000 square feet
we're gonna see a real crisis in terms
of who now takes those spaces while
Ontario has yet to reopen malls British
Columbia relaxed restrictions and gave
the green light even so
Alberta's allowed moles to reopen too
but initially at least there's not that
much appetite for shopping we could have
a lot of consumers that are in much much
worse financial health than they were
only six months ago meaning mall stores
may reopen the choppers won't
automatically show up stores that do
survive may not need as much space as
they had opting instead to focus
strictly on their brand not huge
footprints with stock on hand it may
just be a showroom that people come in
and see it and be able to shop it in the
product is shipped to them at a separate
time smaller spaces cheaper to rent
fewer staff and less money needed to pay
them the future may be worse for
retailers occupying aging malls in
smaller communities where there's little
allure and it was just crowds of people
and the same old malls all up the same
space could give way to new users
recreational and residential as online
shopping driven by a pandemic alters the
way we sell and buy I don't predict to
death at all of the shopping center I
think it is what will it become we will
get beyond the health crisis we will
repair the economic damage and my only
hope is that we find that in actual fact
what the industry did was not it didn't
die it just shed its skin it just shed
about a hundred years of old legacy
retailers and that we have new exciting
retailers that are coming into a market
that might arguably have a lot lower
real estate prices to allow them into it
coming up I'm Kareem in army life and
we're having a baby in the time of
coronavirus a pandemic pregnancy that
ended with a big bundle of joy
[Music]
we've got some happy news to share with
you the miracle of new life back on
Mother's Day weekend we introduced you
to Kareem and Elias they were expecting
a baby and shared their journey of what
it was like to be pregnant during a
pandemic
well the pregnancy is over and
Parenthood has begun
introducing Anderson kit Campbell he was
born May 20th at 7 pounds 8 ounces
he's pretty long and he's got them
pretty big and feet but we will
definitely people hey buddy they're
calling him Andy and he's home safe and
sound the birth didn't go exactly as
planned it rarely does in a few weeks
Kareem and Elias will take us through
that chapter of their story a story of
new life and new beginnings
finally tonight a hopeful note about
someone at a different stage in their
life 78 year old Judy Carson has been
discharged after seven weeks at Royal
Victoria Hospital in Barrie Ontario
three of them in intensive care
her family was told she might not make
it
she got Kovach 19 while on a cruise with
her husband those who cared for her or
as happy as she was that she's going
home they sent her off in style she
calls them her heroes thanks for
watching good night
[Music]